[Music]
I'm just some real-life drama for
another TV family the Kardashians yeah
growing Kanye West and now you'll have a
full on battle not to mention the
perfect episode of celebrity Family Feud
I was exclusively on set as Kim and
Chloe took their sibling rivalry to the
next level Jimmy - Jimmy :
[Music]
[Applause]
no I'm doing this let's talk about the
Kim khloé moment oh boy yeah that she's
not even gonna say hello
like I love Khloe's commitment to you no
yes
filmed in February Chloe was still
pregnant with now seven week old true
the cameras were keeping up were rolling
and Kanye caused some major chaos right
before the taping up until the last
minute we had our very own Family Feud
because we were coming with me and my
girls and all of a sudden Kanye
hijacked family feud he had his own team
reppin team Kanye three of his cousins
and of course wife Kim Kanye wasn't
gonna do it it wasn't the plan and then
when he heard that I was doing it he was
like oh no no no where I've got to come
to name a reason you think Steve
Harvey's a good kisser him I have never
seen Kanye so smiley in my entire life
he was in his element we have it on in
our household at all times name an
occasion when you slip into something
sexy instead of comfortable date night
on team Chris daughters Kendall and
Chloe her mom her cousin and Kim's BFF
Jonathan Cheban
that's the most people the show has ever
had on a panel they won't let me in
their huddle guys who knew that this was
so important to my family I got a
feeling when this game over it ain't
gonna be the same car home I have my own
car today because I'm smart yeah and
there is a surprise ending oh you never
know what's gonna happen this Kardashian
no you never know you never know I'm
June 10th and by the way they played for
charity for Children's Hospital Los
Angeles
[Music]
[Applause]